what was what was the one thing where
you go
a project you did where you were like
i'm good i'm good i can do this you know
what i i was doing this uh i was at sick
well um i was in chicago i got hired by
second city i'd studied there i got
hired by them and that's like the first
like where you feel like holy [ __ ]
because there's a lot of people that
were auditioning over and over again and
didn't get it so i i got in the touring
company um and when i was there stephen
colbert was in the touring company and
not that we weren't in the same touring
company but we knew which like there was
there was like three was he great then
amazing i'm always the best always the
best but i remember john favreau was a
host there and i was working with john
in another theater at the annoyance and
improv olympic but he could not get
hired at second city as an actor he was
just a host which is it's nuts you know
it's so you feel like you get this thing
and it's like this
this um
you know it's a validation right uh and
then um we were doing the show at the
annoyance theater called the real life
brady bunch with jane lynch and then um
and it was uh jill salway at the time
who's now joey salloway um it was uh
their idea and then to do these episodes
of the brady bunch on stage and it was
like this huge hit so wait a minute you
should you actually did episodes yes
re-enacted episodes it was a joke and it
was with the music and did you do the
one where she gets hit in the football
without believing those
yeah we did that yeah and i was i was
jane's understudy for carol brady but
then i took over as alice um the maid
for a while and when i first started i
was thinking like all the non-brain was
so it was so like there was a line down
the block like you when you got last for
that you were like you knew and it was
packed house all the time every time and
then it went off broadway the show went
off broadway so i went with it for some
of that and then it came out here to the
westwood playhouse do you get paid
pretty well for those shows uh not in
chicago we didn't but but we did i
actually went when when it went to new
york we got paid really well dave
kachner um well first andy richter was
mr brady the first one in new york um
but he would do some episodes in in
chicago as well and then dave keckner
took over for him uh in new york for a
while but um anna gastar was in the tour
with me rachel dratch did it new york
like there's a lot of like a lot of
people
[Music]
when is the last time you watched an
episode of smallville town
i mean i i don't even probably forever
what do you say we revisit well
like watch an entire episode
no i mean like watch an entire series
join tom welling and michael rosenbaum
every week as they rewind every episode
of smallville and discuss their
experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast
you